up until i modernly lit wood-paneled
insane asylum five jars on Yelp hello
guys what flare that was let's we come
here for come for the flare stay for the
the travel web series at mamrie Hart and
I have been working on all summer Haley
is finally available in full episodes at
hey we got the scene calm because we've
been spending the summer traveling
around the United States and because
I've been been watching a lot of
iisuperwomanii videos I've been inspired
to talk to you about the taxing people
you encounter on planes I've probably
been on planes as much as I've thought
about nachos this summer that's a lot of
times so I feel like I really grasp the
type of people that you can run into on
planes never grasp someone on plane
wrong place to grasp someone also maybe
never grasp someone the types of people
you experience on planes my silent but
stanky anytime you smell a fart and or
some sort of a rectum queef in your
vicinity on a plane and you look around
and you see that one person that's just
like I am definitely asleep they are not
asleep they are pretending to sleep
because they definitely don't it how do
I know this person exists because I've
been this person like I've never worked
at a casino but I have surely dealt it
what's my favorite airline Delta this is
the person that very clearly is
overcompensating they trying to pretend
that they're asleep
but is definitely leaving some silent
but deadly surround and you know what
it's not something but deadly because
you're still awake it's silent book
purgatory these people are the Prius of
farts other than farting into a vacuum
it's my favorite place to fart next we
have the communicator I hate this person
this is the person that will not stop
talking to anything in anyone around
them on a plane you can make it very
obvious that you do not want to talk to
this person on
the wall can make it very office that
they cannot communicate back with this
person but that will not stop this
person you couldn't even tell this
person to talk to the hand because they
will probably talk to a hand
I believe this happens because this
person is so full of anxiety or nerves
or excitement about flying that they
have to overcompensate by just talking
to get out all of their feelings what's
their favorite television show Project
Runway because as soon as we hit the
runway
they just keep projecting you got that
library ain't no toots before was your
only problem on that plane
uh-uh now you got audible mouth charts
coming right at you
this person cannot be an astronaut
Noorie feng shui
artist because they do not understand
space next you have the story scat this
is a person that is very obviously
nervous to be on a plane but it's very
much trying to now make it obvious so
much so that they might have to scat
they got the nervous then you have the
real friends this is the person that
clearly does not want to be bothered but
isn't gonna make a big deal about it
they're not gonna put up a visual
blockade around themselves saying please
don't acknowledge me they're gonna put
up some very subtle signs that you need
to pick up on and if you're the you know
overeager Corgi that's running towards
freedom you're gonna get zapped how do I
know this person exists because I'm this
person I got my headphones in I don't
want to talk to you I know I can eye
contact because I don't want to talk to
you you ask me about myself I answer in
statements not in questions because I
don't want to continue this conversation
I want to pay but whatever ridiculous
speed it is so that I could have
internet on my flight so I can check my
tumblr tags and my tweets and live in my
narcissistic bubble please and thank you
then you have what classical artists
referred to as the dream aquarium like
at one clear coping mechanism and it's
Claire's Calum vodka gin then you have
the ingredient Youth the baby on the
plane and
you if you look at a baby like you're
pissed off at they're making noise yes a
baby crying on a plane sucks a D but
think about it for a second a baby can
only communicate through crying we Tru
go because we know that we're gonna have
a change in pressure this baby has no
clue so as soon as it's brain starts
going girl as we take off the only way
can communicate is by crying also pretty
sure that baby judge which leads me to
the pure parent parents that have to
deal with babies on the plane god bless
you while you're trying to transport a
baby from point A to point B via plane I
don't know but I try to understand that
what you're doing is very very hard I
can barely get my dog to take a [ __ ] in
the backyard and you got to just walk
behind that little swaying whirling
dervish of piss and emotion up and down
the aisles like you're walking a
two-legged dog that you're teaching a
circus trick to I don't know have you
ever had a nano pet you get it then last
but not least the shower gross this is
that person that falls asleep on the
plane instantly and then does that thing
where they hover over your shoulder as
if they could have dropped towards your
shoulder at any moment which will cause
an awkward social interaction the only
thing we're all striving to avoid every
minute of every day they're like a swing
Jenga tower when Jenga doesn't become
fun anymore because everyone knows it's
about to fall over once it falls over
the only thing left to do is pick the
game up and everyone looks to themselves
like why the should we decide to play
this game this is a stupid game we
should all just be on tumblr and if you
are a shoulder ghost stop that well
there you go there some types of people
that you can run into a place how does
this video helped you in your life I
don't know
make sure that you go watch the bulb so
to pay us a heiio sa java scene calm
guys my book is officially out Grace's
guy do two pretending to be a grown up
it's very exciting so make sure if you
haven't already purchase you can go to
bookstores and purchase it where you can
go online to Grace's guide book comm and
purchase it it's all very exciting
business and guess where is a great
place to read books planes also
everywhere else in life constantly if
you can't read it because you need to
use your hands for things like driving
or hand jobs you can get the audiobook